hold on to your butt's bat-fans director
Matt Reeves has shared images of the new
Batmobile for the upcoming reboot the
Batman and we think it's pretty safe to
say that they do not disappoint in
keeping with past iterations of the
iconic vehicle the new version looks
very lean very mean and very fast show
me my car pretend for a moment you're
some lowlife up to no good in Gotham
City maybe you're pulling off a jewelry
store heist or holding up an armored
truck
is this the absolute last thing you'd
want to see or what here's an overhead
view sleek black and obviously built for
speed
like if a manta ray were an automobile
we're sure you're already sold but wait
we saved the best for last look at that
now that is a car that nobody but Batman
would be capable of driving for more
than a block without wrapping it around
the nearest telephone pole sending it
sky-high in a ball of rocket fuel fed
flames not only are Batman diehards
bound to be drooling puddles over these
photos but we're thinking that if you're
a car person your eyes are popping out
of your head right now I've gotta get me
one of those for starters you've
probably gotten the idea that Bruce
Wayne did not build this car from
scratch and you'd be right
our best guess this vehicle began life
as a 1970 Dodge Challenger a legendary
muscle car that made up for what it
lacked in handling ability with raw
screaming power there are a couple of
other models it could be the Pontiac GTO
s of the late 60s come to mind but given
those deeply recessed headlights
extremely low-profile and distinctive
curves we're pretty sure that Wayne went
with a Dodge you'll know however that
there are a few modern touches the
trapezoidal taillights along with the
rear window mounted third brake lights
are obvious aftermarket modifications
also looking closely at the rear view
you'll notice there is a small video
display mounted in dash touchscreen GPS
units were not in widespread use at the
time the Batman is thought to be set
around the mid to late 2000s but this is
Bruce Wayne we're talking about I'm rich
finally the engine the freaking engine
it looks like an absolutely massive b10
with enormous vertical exhausts up each
side that big ring in the center
afterburner obviously you don't want to
stand anywhere near it ever oh and if
you're wondering if any 60s or 70s
muscle cars featured rear mounted
engines the answer is no not one of them
why on earth would master Bruce have
relocated the engine to the rear of the
car why to make room for something else
under the hood of course something we're
thinking like a big fat array of weapons
and/or gadgets aside from that
afterburner which you know will spit a
gigantic stream of fire this Batmobile
doesn't bear much resemblance to the
iterations we've seen in the past it's
the only version we've ever seen that
looks like a modified commercially
available vehicle even the 60s Batmobile
was based on the Lincoln Futura a
concept car that was never released to
the public the Batmobile driven by
Michael Keaton's Caped Crusader in 1989
s Batman was quite obviously a custom
design with its enormous size necessary
for concealing all the wonderful toys
which it could deploy with Christopher
Nolan's Dark Knight trilogy the
Batmobiles design took an even harder
turn into custom territory dubbed the
tumbler it wasn't so much a car as it
was a highly armoured customizable multi
configuration assault vehicle than the
type that any military worth its salt
would shell out millions for who said
no the tumblin oh you wouldn't be
interested in that in keeping with the
DIY repurposed aesthetic of the new bat
suit though this new Batmobile looks a
bit like a first draft an insanely fast
powerful kick-ass first draft but a
first draft nonetheless perhaps Wayne
will have upgraded by the time we see
the Batman 2 this version though looks
absolutely parotia s-- and it bats
legions of fans haven't whipped
themselves into a frenzy over this flick
before way they get safe for them to
start doing so now chicks dig the car
the Batman hits the big screen on June
25th 2021 check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite movies and TV
shows are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]